hello everyone I'm judge Janine Piro
along with Jessica tarof Brian kilme
Dana Perino and Greg Gutfeld it's 5 o'
in New York City and this is the
five President Biden finally doing what
he should have done days ago
unequivocally supporting Israel and
forcefully condemning Hamas in this
life and I mean this literally when the
pure unadultered evil is Unleashed on
this
world the people of Israel live through
one such moment this
weekend the bloody hands of the
terrorist organization ofas women raped
assaulted paraded as
trophies
families hid Their Fear for hours and
hours desperately trying to keep their
children quiet to avoid drawing
attention we must be Crystal Clear we
stand with Israel we will make sure
Israel has what it needs to take care of
its citizens defend itself and respond
to this
attack President Biden and the White
House confirming that 14 Americans have
been slaughtered by Hamas and 20 US
citizens are missing Biden also saying
that Americans are being held hostage by
Hamas the families of the the victims
kidnapped by the terror group are
begging Biden to act and they are
responsible to bring the US citizens
back home safe and
sound we expect nothing less from the US
Administration in from President Biden
I'm asking the
us not to take a back seat to do what
they can to make this end for us as soon
as possible to become family whole again
again the president showing some
leadership today but where is this
version of Joe Biden been Biden
practically sat silent for two days
without any on camera public statements
as Israel dealt with the worst terror
attack in its history his White House
was forced to clean up after him and
post tweets that claim Biden was quote
receiving regular updates on the
situation from his National Security
Team all right Dana I'll go to you first
okay the president promised that the
United States would stand by Israel 100%
number one why did it take four days for
him to say this and number two how long
do you think this promise will be good
for given the fact that Urban Warfare
which is where we're headed in Gaza can
be extremely long and extremely
difficult well I thought his comments
today once he finally made them had some
moral Clarity to them them I think there
was a missed opportunity to not talk
about Iran but to talk about good versus
evil stand with Israel and you could
quibble with you maybe you could say
this maybe you could say that he doesn't
often do give public comments right away
think back to the Afghanistan withdrawal
there was a period of about 48 hours
maybe 72 hours where he was silent
during that all of that withdrawal and
we kept saying why isn't the president
speaking I don't know why he is so slow
to do that because I imagine that what
he said today is probably what he
thought in ially um perhaps their
internal process is one that it just
takes them a little bit of time uh
another thing that I would have made
very clear is that any Palestinian
killed in these in this response they
are the victims of Hamas as well not the
Israelis and I don't know if that can
help some of the public perception but
social media if you see some of these
some know disgusting excuses being made
about Hamas that is just deplorable and
it is happening kind of all around the
world one of the things that was
shocking to me today was to do a poll to
show a poll from Gallup that in 2013 in
the Democratic party 55% of people in
the Democratic Party 10 years ago
supported Israel today it's only 38%
right why and what is the responsibility
of the leader of the Free World the
leader of the Democrats in order to help
try to turn that around but the Iran
peace was missing today it's not going
to go away the other thing that's
happening is they can delay him getting
out there and making a statement but we
all have are seeing everyone in the
world is seeing exactly what Hamas did
here in real time because of social
media so the old tactic of waiting to
talk doesn't seem to work that well
anymore Brian you know uh as as Dana
mentioned missing from Biden's speech
was Iran but but Biden uh it's the Wall
Street Journal was the one that told us
that Iran was behind it orchestrating it
providing weapons uh training and yet we
don't hear this from the administration
but one of the things Biden said was to
any country thinking of taking advantage
don't and he was very firm but didn't
Iran already do that yeah but I guess he
specifically was thinking about
Hezbollah you know hey if you're going
to start bombing in the North or if
you're going to uh start with Syria with
those Renegade uh Outlets there that
basically has become a terrorist State
there's no doubt about it Iran played a
role calculated the president calls out
Iran directly we could be looking at a
major war so he's being calculated but
there's a ways to insinuate we know
exactly what's going on you know what I
would love to have seen judge I would
love to have seen him say listen I gave
you guys a chance after maximum pressure
campaign I thought Trump was all wrong
the previous administration was all
wrong I gave you a chance I gave you I
met in Oman you weren't weren't supposed
to know about that I I released
sanctions I allowed you to pump out more
oil we saw all that happen and now I
realize it's a mistake back to maximum
pressure pressure here we go again and
the Washington Post expanded on what the
Wall Street Journal said and the
Washington Post said planning began a
year ago and not only did Iran help
tactically they helped set up weapons
manufacturing plants and Hezbollah
pitched in what was so crazy about the
Wall Street Journal story what was it 24
hours after we found out that they were
having bi-weekly meetings in Beirut
excuse me who knew this I would find a
way to call up reporters not threaten
them just say listen this is a huge
problem how the hell did you find that
out after all I don't see that being a
threat just saying if you're comfortable
giving me the sources I would love to
confirm this because this has got to
stop right
now all right Jessica you know Biden
didn't demand that Hamas return those
American hostages or demand that not a
hair on the body of any American be
touched going forward um are you
confident that the president has the
backs of Americans over there absolutely
I mean I've seen bipartisan
support and agulation for this speech I
mean there are people on social media
who were conservatives um very
pro-israel saying that this is a speech
that Barack Obama would not have made uh
when he was in office that this was one
of the more pro-israel speeches you
could ever have envisioned so you know
I'm sorry if maybe he didn't say exactly
the words that you wanted in the order
that you wanted them but his message was
unequivocally clear and I would add to
that that I think that he has been clear
since day one of this he spoke to the
American people on Saturday afternoon he
came out and he said without
equivocation we stand with Israel there
was no uh talk of the Palestinians
making sure that there's no loss of life
in the Gaza Strip said we have your back
in terms of what he's been doing then in
the interim days when he's been
disappointing you I guess that he's not
on camera there was a joint statement um
that came out last night signed by the
US France Germany Italy coming together
speaking out in support of Israel
BB Netanyahu has thanked President Biden
for his support the Israeli ambassador
to the US the Israeli ambassador to the
UN the White House Now lit up in the
Israeli flag colors something that you
upset uh was upsetting you yesterday so
I I don't really get besides kind of
partisan bickering what the problem is
with how Joe Biden has addressed this if
it's good enough for Netanyahu it should
be good enough for
you he's got no choice do he got no
choice we're our number one benefactor
so Israel they have no choice but to
praise just like zilinski has to say
thanks for giving me just enough to
survive not to win because we are their
number one benefactor I will say this
the one thing problem is uh Obama and uh
Obama and Biden have one thing in common
they despise Netanyahu remember he was
whispered telling sarosi I have to deal
with Netanyahu every day he still hasn't
invited him to the White House never
congratulated him on the way he did
invite him to the White House last month
and now there are people like this
former Israeli defense minister who's
calling on the opposition people to not
form an emergency government with
Netanyahu that he needs to resign
netanyahu's problems are at home they
are not with us he's got to he does not
like they do not like each other yeah
they don't and Obama didn't like him and
the bottom line is there's nobody better
than Netanyahu in a situation like this
in a situation like this how do you
negotiate or protect Americans Greg when
the Israelis are being used as human
Shields I don't know I'm not an expert
in that uh I will say that I I thought
it was a strong a strong speech and you
can get you know Petty about the words I
guess but there's a lot of problems with
this
Administration that wasn't a problem I
mean my bar is very low for Joe Biden I
was reli he didn't compare the attack to
a fire in the kitchen so that was good
that's a win in my book however it's not
like I was fortified or empowered by it
because I guess it's just words right
now and I'm waiting for the Deeds I
thought the words were strong but I
always go by the Deeds so we have to
wait and see I know a lot of people were
you know saying why didn't he mention
Iran I don't think that was the that was
the problem I think that right now we
have to talk about our vulnerability
right our immediate threat and we have
one it's called the southern border and
it's unprotected and it would have been
nice for him to say we're going to close
we're going to we're you know treat it
like we did with coid right we got we
got to close the border we got to get
troops down there uh we got to treat
this as a serious threat to the United
States I think that this is a stark
scary moment for the West you know after
911 we were devastated but there was
never a concern that we weren't being
led by a team of people with fortitude
and will uh I feel that right now we're
dealing with a leadership deficit uh and
I'm giving him credit for that for that
speech albeit it was a couple of days
late and he could have done it instead
of going to a barbecue
but right now it's not like we're at
Baseline I feel like we're in a hole
leadership wise and I don't think we can
pretend that we're in a good place right
now and I think we have to wait and see
tonight there it hasn't been a change
all we're getting is bad news so uh I
give him props for for you know
unequivocally being on the side of
Israel but those are the words I want to
see the Deeds all right hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else